on m'a retrouvé tout de suite régis
régis jantes et qui est donc notre
correspondant à tbilissi régis j'ai
évoqué cette demande d'adhésion formulée
la peur des des géorgiens l'inquiétude
vis-à-vis d'une potentielle attaque
russe quelle est elle exactement
aujourd'hui
elle est vraiment elle est vraiment réel
et on se dit que le sort de la géorgie
dépend complètement du sort de l'ukraine
du sort de cette guerre il faut savoir
que le sort de la géorgie et de
l'ukraine depuis 1991 la chute de l'urss
sont complètement lié les deux pays par
exemple on fait partie dès le début des
années 90 d'un certain nombre
d'organisations multilatérales qui leur
permettaient ensemble avec d'autres
petits pays où plus petits pays que la
russie de se liguer en quelque sorte ou
de se défendre contre contre la russie
parle régulièrement de l'ukraine et de
la géorgie dans la même phrase les
associant puisque les deux ont une
féroce volonté de faire partie de l'otan
donc il les associe on se souvient aussi
par exemple qu'en 2008 quelques mois
avant la guerre qui a eu ici qui est un
peu la même guerre elle va beaucoup plus
loin aujourd'hui en ukraine mais qui a
les mêmes causes en quelque sorte et
bien la géorgie et l'ukraine avait
s'était vu en quelque sorte promettre
par l'otan on se met du cac reste en
avril 2008 et bien un jour de faire
partie de cette de cette organisation et
le fait qu'on n'avait pas donné de date
de délai pour cette adhésion avait
encouragé semble-t-il le kremlin moscou
et bien a lancé la guerre en géorgie
grande inquiétude les gens se
rassemblent
cris des saveurs crenna on est vraiment
au côté de l'ukraine et on se fiche
minute par minute ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ukraine tous les russes
ne soutiennent pas aujourd'hui cette
cette guerre cette opération a menée par
le régime de vladimir poutine on a
évidemment tous découvert ces ces images
courage invraisemblable de marina aux
siennes nico va qui a été depuis mis en
examen cette productrice russe qui a
déboulé sur sa chaîne de télévision
alors d'un gîte est extrêmement regarde
ayant en russie pour dénoncer la
propagande
russe ilya nombreux journalistes
intellectuels issus du monde culturel
aussi qu'ils ont décidé ces derniers
jours ces dernières heures de de fuir la
russie de vladimir poutine certains on
l'a déjà couverts dans nos éditions ont
été accueillis en turquie en arménie
d'autres se tournent vers la géorgie
l'accueil qui leur est réservé est
peut-être un peu plus froid un peu plus
réservé en tout cas
effectivement on parle de 25 ou 30 mille
russes qui se sont
exilés en géorgie ces derniers jours et
on dans le quartier où je me trouve au
centre de la ville on entend de russes
partout dans les rues dans les cafés
dans les restaurants on a pour une part
des gens de l'opposition notamment de
télévision d'orge ou la radio echo de
moscou qui sont venus ici et puis des
gens des familles entières parce qu'ils
peuvent plus parce qu'ils veulent pas de
cette russie parce qu'ils ont peur des
sanctions et c'est effectivement à
l'accueil est un peu mitigé puisque en
géorgie on a tendance à penser que que
l'impérialisme dont le pays est victime
je rappelle que la géorgie à deux
régions séparatistes qui ne se sont
séparés que par le soutien enfin la
géorgie a pu faire des erreurs mais
c'est essentiellement parce que là
moscou a soutenu au début des années 90
ces régions séparatistes qu'elles ont
fait sécession l'abkhazie et l'ossétie
du sud et on estime que ce n'est pas
seulement la sphère du pouvoir mais
c'est aussi en partie la sphère de la
population qui accepte cela peut être
pas les gens qui sont venus ici donc
effectivement ça fait que le l'accueil
est un petit peu un peu mitigé parfois
envers ces russes on rappelle notamment
que ces régions l'abkhazie et l'ossétie
ont fait sécession non pas
avant la question de l'otan et c'est
parce que il ya eu ces sessions que la
géorgie a perdu 20 % de son territoire
et bien qu'on sait tourner ensuite vers
l'otan donc derrière tout cela en fait
on voit le résultat de l'impérialisme
russe qui ne serait pas seulement
l'impérialisme du pays en tout cas c'est
la lecture qu'on a ici en géorgie merci